America hitting a single day high for
new coronavirus cases Texas Florida and
California among the states with the
biggest spikes and New York's Governor
Andrew Cuomo thinks now is the perfect
time to play politics and attack red
states despite his own failures stopping
the virus I say to them all look at the
numbers you play politics with this
virus and your loss now you see 27
states with the numbers going up you see
the death projections going up you see
the economy going down who was never
politics it was always science and they
were in denial and denial is not a life
strategy all right Greg don't let's not
play politics but I'm gonna play
politics and blame everybody else except
myself right yeah I mean it I think they
got they've got to get over this
tit-for-tat thing because frankly
everybody at one point during this whole
thing was wrong including the experts
New York isn't doing that great it ranks
what 48 out of 50 in survival rates so
we should be a little bit more humble
especially after after the nursing home
thing but a lot of people made mistakes
we also know and we have to be we have
to be optimistic we got a look at the
death count and I think the death count
is like in the United States overall is
down 80% if I can fact check me out but
I'm pretty sure but we knew we knew
cases would rise as young people started
going out again
that summer interaction people still
have to be safe you got to wear your
masks you got to take the precautions
with distance and do that but I am I
believe that I'm I'm turning myself into
a slim gorgeous stimulus package I need
to go out into the community and spend
the money that I haven't spent and put
it back in there and get the economy
back on its feet
I'll be wearing a mask I'll be six feet
away but I'm going out there because
it's it's time we all have to be
stimulus packages I just happen to be a
very sexy one yeah oh god Greg Gutfeld
the slim sexy stimulus package and tan I
might add all right Dana what do you
think about Cuomo patting himself on the
back I mean they had a tough time in New
York I don't
now is the time for congratulations well
you know if you're surrounded by a media
that tells you you're so awesome you're
maybe going to believe it the other day
I watched CBS Sunday morning which is a
show that I love I've loved it my whole
life and I watched the interview that
Jane Pauley did with the governor and
she never even asked him about the
nursing home policy and it was all about
how he's this amazing bachelor who lives
up in this mansion and maybe he should
like date somebody it was it's shocking
and maybe for punishment I'll make Gregg
watch it so we can do another monologue
about the media it's really unbelievable
I will also say this though the I had
the mayor of Miami on the daily briefing
yesterday and he said he understands
Governor Cuomo's position about having
people from Florida quarantine he said
not going to quibble with that that they
really want to do the right thing and
make sure that people are safe so there
are some people who aren't playing
politics Juan Williams obviously as Greg
mentioned at the top there's going to be
more cases we were told to expect more
cases as we flatten the curve do you see
in your opinion a second wave on the
horizon potentially or do you see this
as just what we heard was going to
happen well I think you told me you
don't believe in the second way right
Jesse so I I don't you know people like
right so I don't I just listen to foul
Qi I listen to the CDC director and they
say we're still in the first wave and
you know the surprise to me is that I
thought a lot of this would die down
during the summer months in any case
with regard to Cuomo I just think he's
not so much playing politics as the
tables have turned it used to be that
New York was in dire shape and now the
big spikes are elsewhere in the country
especially in the south and the
southwest and you know he's just saying
to them it's you know those people were
telling New Yorkers they couldn't come
to their state and now the tables have
turned and he wants Cuomo wants to
protect New Yorkers from experiencing
another wave of this virus and I would
just add that Senator Cornyn of Texas
urging President Trump not to withdraw
money for testing because he sees what's
going on in Texas yeah I mean I think
the difference is you're not seeing a
spike in deaths in the other states like
you saw the spike in deaths in New York
State all right Dagan McDowell what do
you think before any more bragging from
Governor Cuomo how about taking
responsibility for the thousands of
elderly people in nursing homes who died
because of your executive order Florida
by the way had 5,000 fewer deaths in
nursing homes because they ban kovat
positive patients from going into said
nursing homes
I watched the Como bro show last night
and here's what the governor said
there's no doubt we have to figure out
how to do it better next time talking
about the nursing homes
oh you mean not killing people by
exhibit by a decree from the governor's
mansion I would use the word asshat here
but that will be an insult to hats and
actual asses why I feel like I'm on the
Greg Gutfeld show it's just a good
experience